[Applaudissements]
ces bâtiments sont pas vraies
active
[Applaudissements]
des tomates a été tu étais pas bien
quand même
non j'étais mon corps et me lâchait
ouais j'avais perdu 12 13 kg tout stress
qu'il joue strauss kg comment tu te sens
tu es tu sentais que tu vois que tu
pouvais plus tenir
moi je mettais un pied devant l'autre
dès que je me dis que je me mettais
debout je tourne la tête elle tournée tu
as une âme et m'envoie pour ta santé ou
pas non j'avais pas peur parce qu'on a
un très bon suivi ja lemay rien si on a
besoin et le médecin qu'est ce qu'il
disait médecin bas me disais que ça
allait un faux choix que quand je me
mettais debout enfin que la tête elle
tournée mais après ça a l'air qui vous à
florian philippot m'appelle et me dit
lève le pied que le modem je suis dit
pourquoi je pourquoi je devrais lever le
pied avec le modem
il me dit tu dis plus rien je suis dit
bas à tanger en cours du journaliste
carrie je vais paraître comme une carpe
et tout ça dit non mais je t'expliquerai
ans je pousse le bouchon je réécoute
florian mais tant que tu me dises
compris voilà tu me dis et il m'a dit
bon écoute
elle vient de sortir de chez bayrou et
donc tu lève le pied et après le monteur
non mais sur twitter en voyant les
départs mais dans des conversations non
parce que nous avons des conversations
privées non on va aider des proches de
florian philippot et des assistants du
front qui dirait on va vivement qu'on
ait une loi d'exception une loi
d'amnistié mis d'accord voilà c est fait
une affaire d'état
alors c'est juste une affaire d'état
mais quitter leur n a jamais su ça j'ai
quitté leur haine alors moi j'étais pas
d'emplois fictifs ou peut être un emploi
fictif en sens inverse c'est à dire je
me suis gt1 j'ai eu un engagement de
quatre années complètement bénévole doit
avoir une investiture qui correspondent
à la fois votre engagement et à vos
compétences appel à un cabinet cohen et
may en ayant uni fans ayant eu une
reconnaissance ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre une raison de vous allez suivre
est resté non je pense quand même
honnêtement ma marine est une personne
que je respecte beaucoup
sauf que son entourage
les iai et non le nom son entourage et
non c'est non et non ses conseillers
plus influents il ya des gens qui ont
une appli qui ont l'ampleur
intellectuelle d'un balais d'essuie
glace on est d'accord mais s'efface
didier deschamps va annoncer que karim
benzema revient en équipe de france moi
ça me réjouit jean missia pour vous
c'est une mauvaise idée le retour de
karim benzema
alors mon opinion et vous livre les
sticks en parlant des mondes opinion sur
les talents footballistiques de karim
benzema que je reconnais volontiers ce
qui me gêne si vous voulez c'est que là
on est en train de parler de l'équipe de
france c'est quelque chose là l'équipe
de france est une des rares institutions
dans laquelle tout le monde se reconnaît
encore quelles que soient les origines
sociales professionnelles ethnique et
donc je veux qu'il y ait dans l'équipe
de france des gens qui incarnent la
france
or excusez moi mais quand karim benzema
en 2006 nous dit que son pays c'est
l'algérie nous dit qu'il veut pas jouer
qu'il aurait volontiers joué en algérie
mais que sportivement comprenez pour une
histoire d'argent il préfère jouer en
france lorsque il ne chante pas la
marseillaise lorsque il crache par terre
après la marseillaise jouée en l'honneur
des morts du bataclan - quel pays au
monde à commencer d'ailleurs par son
pays d'origine c'est à dire l'algérie
accepterait dans son équipe nationale un
joueur qui ne chante pas son hymne
national ou qui crache par terre après
l'hymne national on va pas aller
reprocher un joueur de foot
non mais vous pouvez pas ne pas la
chanter aussi ça chagrine donc ça me
chagrine que ce soit plus fait dans
d'autres pays ont perçu en france
mais si on n'explique pas à l'école et
si on abandonne depuis 30 ans maintenant
by ce qui est relatif à la nation et à
la clinique ce que vos partis
extrémistes un vrai problème le climat
le climat sociétale en france est
extrêmement tendue mais on est pris dans
une dans une tenaille aujourd'hui qui
est en gros l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche est ce que je vois moi
dans cette décision c'est une volonté de
dialogue et de conciliation amour de
mccain je pense que rageant du mois vide
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un de cracher non mais les
migrants que j'ai rencontrés ne sont pas
des migrants économiques ce sont des
gens dont le prof de mathématiques était
décapité sont des gens dont les mains de
la mer ont été tranchées à faire au cas
parce son nom mais moi je fais au cas
par cas c'est à dire que les erythréens
que j'ai rencontré les afghans que j'ai
rencontrés sont des gens qui auraient
adoré rester chez eux ce sont d eric
zemmour chez eux sur des gens qui
n'aiment pas les voyages qui n'aiment
pas les étrangers qui n'aiment pas
déménager les rencontrer que des gens
qui sont partis parce que c'est une
question de vie ou de mort et quand je
leur demandais quel était le plus grand
rêve de leur vie
c'était pas de se geler dans les quêtes
dans les taillis de calais en attendant
d'être dans un pays qui leur dit rien
qui l'angleterre où il pleut tout le
temps mais de rester chez eux
moi ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
retourner dans un record dans un
confinement dans un
c'est ça la crainte de tout bon soir est
ce un plaisir alors là ça va merci il ya
gabriel céline je ne veux pas si les
basques et jean baptiste
mais moi je vais prendre moi chaque
fondre je prends deux mois un petit à
petit le diabolo fraise je prends à coca
zéro
merci non mais c'est ça c'est ça la
question qu'on se pose c'est vrai que
c'est ça nous fait on est tellement
heureux de sortir que on se dit on
espère qu'on va pas on va pas y
retourner mais quand même je vais quand
même bientôt s'il vous plaît c'est pour
moi j'avais tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
ces quatre amis enseignants
merci jamais me vire je vais quand même
jeu s'il vous plaît
voilà ce que vous voulez
mais bon moi s'est passé extrêmement
vite
en l'espace de 24 heures je passe de 10
% de poumons affecté à 81 pratiquement
et je tombe à une saturation de 82 donc
j'ai énormément de mal à respirer je
rentre directement en réa et j'ai l'âge
et le médecin qui vient me voir et qui
me qui me dit écoutez monsieur zougari
je vais être honnête avec vous le
médecin était jeune il me dit je vous
cache pas que vous êtes mal en point
vous avez une chance sur quatre de vous
en sortir et je n'ai pas de produit
miracle à vous donner
et à ce moment là je dis j'accepte ce
qui m'arrive
parce que je commence à avoir un voile
blanc qui arrive et là je me laisse
aller
je me laisse aller parce que on peut pas
lutter il n'y a pas de ya pas de n'y a
pas de surhommes dans la maladie voilà
j'ai c'est comme si tu t'es date est
allongé qui avec quatre personnes qui
étaient sur ta poitrine
donc le moindre effort ça te ça te pompe
d'une énergie et avec le mal de crâne et
tout ça et puis si tu veux la
réanimation
on ne ressort jamais inde m j'ai encore
des particules de kobe dans mes poumons
j'étais hier chez le pneumologue
ça va bien mais je suis pas encore sorti
quoi je pense que j'en ai au moins pour
un an
nous aimions à la limite tout les
j'appelle mon père oui oui ils croient
pas tu sais que c'est précipité toi
l'ouverture des terrasses ou pas ce que
je dis je ne dis pas que c'est précipité
c'est les gens qui se sont précipités à
bien les gens se précipiter en fait tout
le montrer quand il a dit quelque chose
il faut arrêter un peu
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc des gens intelligents peuvent
faire des abrutis là pour faire des
affaires
merci les accusés simplement dire vive
l'algérie vive l'algerie mois le soin de
se défendre tout au moins que ça soit le
tribunal vive l'algérie à la dim team
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car
ça marche un vaccin est nominé blanche
avec senna mais tout le monde nous parle
d'un danger mais comment ça marche un
vaccin est reine est ce que vous savez
on peut expliquer simplement jean est ce
que c'est la dernière chose est la chose
la plus importante on dit souvent que la
rn change le code génétique oui eh bien
figurez-vous que le code génétique l'adn
il est là où ça ici à l'intérieur dans
le noyau la rn ne va jamais dans l'adn
jamais votre matériel génétique ne sera
jamais jamais à changer la seule chose
qui va se passer c'est que votre système
immunitaire va créer lui-même les
anticorps par bernard je dois revenir
montbernard hier te dis vive l'algérie
oui à l'émission franchement voilà états
unis mais s'il vous plaît et a eu un
déferlement de haine
ah oui dès monaco variable qu'est ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui mais toute la
journée ça a été un déferlement
incroyable
je tiens d'abord cam a remercié alors il
ya eu des milliers franchement des
milliers d amis ça de ma vie de gens qui
me disaient d'abord kim affirmé leur
soutien et qui m'aimait des coeurs c'est
très bouleversée aujourd'hui très ce
soit qui te sens vraiment très ému
bernard team moi ça fait quatre ans que
je subis ça je n'ai jamais eu le droit à
une émission je n'ai jamais eu droit
salaire dérisoire des messages comme on
vient de le faire ce soir là rien à voir
toi tu aimes tu as eu droit au retour
c'est bien qui je pense moi je pense pas
mal et où la personne je pense à tous
les gens qui me tous les jours sans
insulter sur les réseaux sociaux qui
reçoivent des menaces de mort mais vous
aussi pourquoi pas bon non mais bon face
au vaudois rendent assez de mots je vous
ai ni dans le groupe g ral et un hub est
hâtif
non il ya des gens qui méritent la
vendent déjà on ne cherchait pas
dévisser doit habiter mais pas des
autres c'est vous c'est moi plus eu de
l'arrêté est arrivé